beaucoup d'émotion et de gravité
aujourd'hui pour la première journée de
ce procès historique
un procès qui se déroule sous
surveillance avec énormément de forces
de l'ordre des contrôles de sécurité
pour accéder aux salles quatre salles en
tout pour accueillir des centaines de
personnes parmi ces personnes évidemment
les victimes les parties civiles
également leurs avocats la presse du
public venu assister à ce procès
historique est aujourd'hui dans la salle
d'audience on pouvait ressentir
l'émotion la tristesse de victimes et de
et deux parties civiles marqué à vie par
cette tragédie derrière les masques vous
pouvez reconnaître rice ou coco de
charlie hebdo ainsi que patrick peloux
ancien collaborateur de charlie hebdo
également l'as annaba tilly le magazine
et de l'hyper cacher je vous propose de
les écouter
ouais c'est vrai dire c'est très
difficile d'être là ce matin c'est une
cause de la justice pour que l' on veut
vraiment que l'accès soit fait pour moi
déjà ça fait c'est dire de le regarder
parce que pour moi c'est que ça soit les
accusés
les tueurs sont tous parés pour moi
c'est tout pareil parce qu'ils apporter
des soutiens des touristes lé tireur
pour moi j'ai mis tous dans le même
panier voir émotions qu'on a je crois
que c'est très difficile
voyez il faut laisser le temps de la
justice je m'exprimerai après d'accord
d'être super lors de la matinée l'appel
des parties civiles et des témoins a été
fait les prévenus sont apparus ne sont
que 11 sur les 14 puisque trois d'entre
eux sont ensuite ou présumés morts
donc les prévenus sont masquées menotté
sont gardés par des forces de l'ordre
cagoulés ils pourront s'exprimer c'est
ce qu'a expliqué le président ils n'ont
pas invoqué leur droit au silence et ses
explications sont très importantes
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet
samia maktouf l'avocate de lassana
batterie c'est pas le fait qu'ils aient
accepté de répondre aux questions en
maintenance et le le sens des questions
qui va imposer qui va faire que le
contenu soit suffisamment clair de
natura a éclairé pour la manifestation
de la vérité et c'est toute la question
déterminer le degré d'implication des
contacts des frères kwasi et dames et 10
coulibaly avait t-il connaissance du
projet terroriste lorsqu'ils ont fourni
des hommes ou autre matériel en tout cas
on a pu apprendre que l'un des frères
kwasi surveiller très scrupuleusement
ses victimes avant de passer à l'acte et
camées dit coulibaly avait constitué un
véritable arsenal terroriste avec
énormément d'armes
comment at il était aidé et bien à la
lecture du rapport on se rend compte que
certains prévenus semble plus impliqué
que d'autres la question de la
provenance des armes a aussi été abordée
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir de la
première journée de ce procès historique
ici au tribunal de paris